le personnage que je joue, je suis bloqué en tant que gars
qui est allé au Costa Rica et a
lancé un site Web de jeu sur Internet et il est
devenu extrêmement réussi en parlant
7 7,2 millions par jour, ce genre d'argent
au milieu du Costa Rica crée ce
genre de fou  dynamique comment le Far West
le genre de pot-de-vin que tout le monde attire et
toutes ces filles, ces joueurs et ces
arnaqueurs c'est le monde comme nous le voyons quand
nous entrons dans la vie des blocs Richie je
te regarde je me vois malmené même en
disant que tu n'étais pas assez bon et  vous
avez quelque chose pour prouver que ce que le bloc
veut sortir de Richie est de le faire faire
partie de son armée et je pense qu'il utilise
la fierté et l'ambition de Richie
oui mes remerciements à vous vous ne
bloqueriez pas les séjours qu'il veut vous voir
bloquer  veut le manipuler pour
qu'il ne s'oppose pas à certaines des choses qu'il
voit par la fenêtre mais j'envoie un
message tu m'as mis en place c'est ton travail
ton patron dit que tu dois sortir
et prendre une raclée  va là-bas, prends-le,
reviens  k travailler et dire avez-vous besoin de moi
pour le refaire il sait sur quels boutons
appuyer sur les gens tout le monde a quelque chose
qui les intéresse plus que l'argent pour
savoir ce que c'est alors vous devez faire la chose la plus
difficile chaque fois que quelqu'un le
croise ils viennent  jusqu'à manquer
quelle que
soit la voix ce ne sont pas vos passions ses
pieds
vous